- Go detailed, that's
what this part's for.
We're going general on the other stuff.
(mid tempo electronic music)
Oh yeah, I mean Amazon, Apple,
Google, Facebook, the reason
they're so big is they're the
toll booth of the internet.
- [Man] Right so in the past,
the brands were off on the street street-
fighting for the people
walking buy to buy food.
- I genuinely believe that 7-Eleven
and Burger King are in deep
shit in a 30 year window.
This is about timing.
You're very thoughtful, I've
listened a couple times.
Everybody here, I will
tell you the biggest thing
that I've gotten better at, the lessons
I learned as a kid even
though I was right,
I literally built my dad's entire
business strategy for Wine Library
when I took over in '98.
This is true, that by the year 2000 which
is 24 months from then, everybody would
walk into our liquor store with a phone
and have technology that would give them
the price of every product in the country
in order of best price
and that's literally
how I decided to sell everything at cost
that anybody knew and then
build up other brands.
It was great 'cause it
really worked because
we were the price leader of
every wine anybody wanted.
We still don't do that, it is now 2019.
We have close-ish capability,
we have that capability-ish.
There is something called Wine Searcher
if you're a big wine
buyer that aggregates,
it's there but not one person will
walk into Wine Library this year.
Best Buy, where people look
up stuff on Amazon, you know?
So I was wrong about timing.
What I'm good at now, people
are like "Yeah, he's so right,"
I'm good at timing.
That's why I didn't bet on VR.
That's why I don't bet on AR.
That's why I don't bet on machine learning
or things of that nature.
I know every one of those
things is gonna happen.
The question is when,
right?
So,
yes, what you're saying is right.
The question for you is how
are you overthinking it?
So would I say you should go buy
a bunch of buildings for restaurants,
that may not work but
when that's at scale,
when ordering food on Alexa
is at scale or Google,
you could be talking about
a good seven, 10 years.
- Could be even more, right?
- It could be more.
I think that's, you know
I don't, I'm guessing.
That feels ish, you know?
You start thinking about seven,
here's what you have to look at.
Who's doing it all the time?
If anybody here has three
to nine year old kids
in their life, they definitely
see that those humans
think about voice very
differently than we do.
So in seven, eight years
when they're in high school
and have the capability of
having some money or whatever,
they're gonna start
doing things differently.
That's how everything happens.
That's how online dating happened.
Online dating was around for a long time.
It didn't become acceptable
until the generation
that only talked on AIM
and all that, got it?
So you have to look at consumer behavior.
I'll tell you the bigger thing is
gonna be the infrastructure of last mile.
Who's gonna deliver it?
- And so maybe--
- So for example,
I think there's gonna
be a ton of restaurants
that don't have a physical location,
that are just sitting under
buildings and have a kitchen.
- It already exists today.
- It's 100%.
- Already today.
- That's right.
- [Man] Maybe that's what
this app is gonna be.
- That's what everybody's gonna be.
- [Man] So and do you
think in that context,
there is gonna be almost no brands left?
- No, I think brand's the only thing left.
- [Man] But like how many because--
- As many as there are now.
I think that to your point,
"Alexa or Google or phone,
send me a cheeseburger"
but there will be brands that say
"Send me a Shake Shack burger"
or McDonald's or Burger King.
I think, I don't think
brand has to go away.
I think you're making a valid point
but I don't think you
realize how many people
don't buy based on brand.
- Right.
- Like people, the amount
of people here who bought
a cheeseburger and they
actually didn't give a fuck,
it was just the first one in the airport
that had a cheeseburger and whether it
was Tim Horton's, McDonald's, you know,
Burger King or something
else, they didn't care,
well that happens every day.
That's why private labels
are doing well, right?
And convenience is king.
But brand is queen and she runs shit.
The amount of brands
allowed are completely
predicated on how well
brands are executed.
I think store, you gotta think
about what one buys, right?
Like a cheeseburger, I mean everybody,
like look, I think you're
gonna buy your toothpaste,
you're gonna buy it from Alexa
and it's gonna be in your
home within three minutes.
That's awesome.
Buying a fucking pair of sneakers
that way is not awesome
for a lot of people.
There's still people that
want to see and touch it.
So you have to figure out what,
commodities are in trouble.
7-Eleven is in trouble.
Convenience stores and bodegas
are in trouble, I really believe that.
We overpay, everybody
here has paid more for
something that they knew
they could buy somewhere else
because it was right there, instead you
didn't drive to Wal-Mart or
Costco or Saintsbury, right?
Well that convenience is about
to get really convenient.
So it's convenience, it's brand, right?
There's all the same things that have
always dominated humans will always play.
That's why I'm obsessed with brand
because with voice, to your point,
I pull up a Google search in
2003 when that was the game,
even you might've been better
at, I was the best at it.
Wine Library was better than everybody.
Even Wine.com, I was
better than everybody.
That's why it got big but people
still saw their store that they were
actually looking for
and not me below, right?
They typed in Cabernet,
they wanted to buy from
the supermarket, they
saw the Wine Library ad,
I got a lot of them but
I didn't get everybody
and they would go to where they wanted.
Here if I say "Wine" Amazon controls that.
So what I need them to
say is "Wine Library."
That's why brand is so important.
Because if they're gonna
say "Send me supplements,
"I want creatine," you're finished.
Because you're not gonna be
able to afford affiliate fee.
The amount of money that Google, Apple,
Amazon or whoever else
wins this is gonna be
able to charge brands like
Ricard to be (sharp warbling),
to be the default brand are gonna make
slotting fees in stores
look like a fucking picnic.
- [Man] Do you think Amazon would
also as well make their own brands--
- 100%.
- Private labels first--
- 100%, 100%, they'll be strategic.
They'll do what they've always done.
They'll pick and choose, if Ricard's
willing to really pay, then fuck it.
We'll get to whatever, shave,
whatever, in three years.
But if nobody's willing to pay,
fuck it, we'll do it ourselves or
they're gonna look at data.
Everyone's asking for shampoo,
it's now a viable enough thing
for us to do our own shampoo.
Voice is a big one
because it's not visual.
Visual still gave us options.
Voice, we're gonna have no control
other than one thing, brand.
"Alexa, send me Twinkies."
Not chocolate cupcakes, that matters.
That's why I keep building brand,
that's why brand is forever.
- [Man] Which is why I
think quality is the game.
- Yeah, of course--
- Come after us,
like every time they launch--
- Of course.
- A private label.
- [Man] But then people will
go away 'cause it's like shit.
- But quality where, to your point,
and that has examples where the quality,
you had a big enough advantage
in the actual consumer's
point of view, not your own.
Where a lot of brands are gonna lose
and why they lost the private label game
is they assumed that the quality delta was
gonna be enormous and in
some categories, it wasn't.
So correct, your R and D capabilities
are the delta.
But convenience is a son of a bitch, boy.
It's a fucking son of a bitch.
There are people literally going to
a Saintsbury or Wal-Mart or a supermarket
wanting to buy your product but because
it's one shelf lower and this one's here
and they know they don't like it as much,
they just fucking, they don't
have the second for you.
It's crazy.
How to be a brand that makes somebody
willing to be inconvenient
is the fucking Holy Grail.
How are you so good that I'm
willing to go out of my way to have you?
- [Man] Okay.
Thanks.
- Yeah.
That's the real answer.
433.
- 433.
Yeah, you know the company?
- I know all about it.
- [Man] Yeah so we're building out more
now that we have the platform.
- Yeah.
- Instagram going very well.
- I'm aware, yep, yep.
- [Man] Now all that took place,
we have the most engaging
Instagram platform.
So that's good.
- It's huge.
It's the most important
platform and you're one of
the most important products
on the platform, it's huge.
- [Man] Yeah at the moment but internally
we discuss, we have our app with
two million downloads,
Facebook is going also.
We have 2.5 million followers on Facebook.
But that was also my question.
What about other channels or the focus?
We have a community, we
have the fans but yeah.
- It's so crazy, I don't
know if you saw it, this was
literally the post I just posted
on Instagram this morning.
- [Man] I didn't see it.
- I think my post is something like if
Instagram disappeared
today, so would 98% of you.
Because everyone's so one-dimensional.
What should you do?
You should start a podcast
365 days a year.
You should post two
times a day on YouTube.
You should figure out the business
version and put in on LinkedIn.
You should start your own
text messaging platform.
You should build up your own email.
- Just all of that.
- All of it.
You need the platforms because
you need the retention,
you siphon it and you need
your own first party data,
email and texting because
you need to own it.
- [Man] Do you think
also our own platform--
- Yep.
Sure.
433.com.
- Yeah.
- Yep.
- So we have all the data.
- You're receiving the traffic
and the cookies and the first party data.
All of it, events, yep, apparel, mm hmm.
All of it.
- [Man] Clear.
We're opening--
- And the beauty is
you're in a great spot.
That's the answer to everybody
but you have something big already.
You just have to throw right hooks in 433.
Look at my post, I
always say watch what I,
you know, look what I'm doing.
Like three posts ago, that post I took
five years ago where I point because
I want you to turn on my Notifications.
I'm always gathering attention, right?
I'm putting the final touches
on my new text messaging platform.
I had it for awhile, first in line.
The tech wasn't strong,
about to re-roll it out
and when I re-roll it
out and you'll see it,
I'm gonna throw a right
hook, like one post
is just gonna be a black
box with a phone number.
Like that's gonna be the post.
I don't give a fuck that it's gonna
get 22,000 Likes instead of 200,000.
I want the fucking phone numbers.
People get caught up in bullshit.
Literally I know this happens in your
company whether it's you or somebody else,
you hear so much about winning the day
on a post on Instagram, you're
not siphoning out the IP.
You know, this is what happens.
You're like, your next post should be like
"Sign up for our email list."
It's not gonna do as
well as the fucking clips
but it's gonna be much more
valuable for your business.
- [Man] Yeah.
Yeah, we are now so
critical of what we post
because we want to be,
have the high engagement.
- Yep.
- [Man] And be high in the algorithm.
- [Man] So but I totally
understand what you're saying.
- You're pandering to Instagram.
- [Man] Yeah.
- There are people that were
the biggest on MySpace too.
- [Man] Yeah and now, yeah, it's gone.
We're opening a second
office in New York City.
- Awesome.
- Yeah.
So we signed up last week.
- That's awesome.
I'll see you soon, you
guys are doing great.
- [Man] Yeah so I want to catch you up--
- Please.
- Yeah.
- Who are the people
that buy these things?
(laughs)
- [Man] The buyer is quite
often the actual user.
- I understand, that makes sense.
- There is the user.
- Of course, of course.
Yes, I understand.
To really get the rider
and really get the dad,
to your point, you got it, it's Instagram
and LinkedIn or Instagram and
Facebook or Snap and Face,
but the creative, everything's
fundamentally different.
It's just being in the mindset
of actually marketing to both of them
and being, back to
being a good footballer.
Like you might be better at
LinkedIn than you are at Instagram.
- Yeah.
- You know?
I'm better at video
than I am written word.
Right?
So I think but yes, of
course you can do that
and I'm very bullish on
LinkedIn advertising.
- Yeah?
- I really am.
For consumer goods too.
LinkedIn's underrated.
They built fucking Facebook and there's
business people on there and all you have
to do is if you're selling them soap,
make it about how efficient
their business day
will be if they use your
soap, you know like,
you have to make it contextual.
People always talk about awareness
but they don't talk about relevance
and the biggest problem is
everybody talks about awareness
as potential awareness
versus actualized awareness.
So what I love about Facebook
and Instagram and YouTube,
it's actually being consumed
and you can actually make
contextual creative for it.
That's why it's so much better.
- [Man] When you talk
about contextual creative,
are you going after a
psychographic profile or is it--
- Both, both, psycho and demo.
Right?
- Okay.
- And the platforms have that information.
But like you know on
LinkedIn that the person
works at RBS or went to
Cambridge, like you know.
I don't know how people
haven't figured this out.
When I say haven't figured it out,
I think we do a bad job
of layering common sense.
It's so effective, the problem is
nobody realized how much creative it took.
That's where everybody got fucked
including, it took me a little while.
It's just so much creative.
Like back to personal
brand for some of you,
like some of the stuff
we're starting to do,
it's like "Hey Detroit, Hey Texas."
Like the stuff I'm doing for Empathy,
I sat there for like 20 minutes
and did like 73 different beginnings.
"Hey, did you fuck up,"
this is literally one,
"Hey, did you fuck up Valentine's Day?"
We're running that right now.
"Don't ever fuck that up again.
"Order a subscription
to Wine and you don't
"have to think about buying
her a gift anymore, dudes."
You know, like it's, you know?
We literally picked the highest net worth
counties in America,
literally from Wikipedia
which is like probably clean-ish data
and I just was like "Hey Huntington Beach,
"Hey Summerville, Hey
Hunter," like literally
and then you run it
and it converts better.
But what everybody else did
was what I did for years.
"Hey everybody, you
should pick up this wine."
Run it to everybody.
Think about if you guys
made contextual creative
as Instagram ads to just
the football team that
person actually liked.
I don't look at Patriot highlights
on my football Instagram
accounts, you know?
And then you could make the inside
joke of razzing the rival, right?
Now you're relevant.
When they, I mean literally when
you see a LinkedIn at that says
"Hey dad, do you have a daughter?"
Here's what's really cool
though about going broad.
If your LinkedIn ad said "Hey dad,
"do you have a daughter that rides?"
What's interesting is LinkedIn
and Facebook do not have
that data for the most part.
But if you go high net worth,
if you go into cliche, right?
That human if it's a
good piece of creative
is gonna pass that on to his nephew whose
daughter rides or his boss, you know?
That's what's amazing about social.
Nobody rips out a fucking
newspaper ad and brings it,
you know, like think about it, right?
Or watches a commercial,
takes out their phone,
records it and fucking, but people do
pass on social creative that's good.
Be like "Hey, do you
know about this company?"
- Yeah.
- See where I'm going?
- [Man] Yeah.
- So that's the reason to go broad.
Social media is special, I just
don't understand how people don't see it
and let me rephrase, it's hard.
It's hard, it's new, it's
the reverse of the old world.
It's literally the reverse.
It's all bottom-up instead of top-down.
So it just doesn't come natural to people
because most people are
not consumer-centric.
It came natural to me because
I grew up in a retail store
selling, knocking door to door.
It was only the customer,
there was no academia.
There was no thesis,
there was no consulting
and it was always, I
was always on the hook.
Even people that are street
kids that go into companies
immediately aren't on the hook.
So that's how I got there, you know?
It's taken awhile for me to
realize why but that's the game.
Got anything?
- Yeah.
Apart from the starting a
business question we talked--
- By the way, on that, back
to 'cause you set it up,
the answer is yes, you
just run a marathon.
When you have to be profitable,
what you're gonna learn and that's why
I think we've got the
model down and you'll
do it internally with us, somebody else
is you'll get math that works for you.
You just won't be able to scale it
in a way that somebody who's losing
money every day could scale it but
as somebody who competed against Wine.com
that had $168 million in funding and I had
nothing and I won, it's
because 2000 happened.
When the world melts, all
these DTC brands are finished.
Finished.
They're completely built on the next round
until they sell it to one of you
and I think you guys, and not you,
you know but like macro CPG big brands
are finished because channel conflict.
Because it's deja vu.
The best bet I ever made was
when the internet collapsed,
I was only 24 years old.
All the stock market
collapsed, April 2000, dead.
Right?
I bought Amazon because
it was the first time
I understood that Wall
Street, because I didn't know,
was different than real life.
Amazon was gonna win
but Wall Street did different shit.
You know 'cause it just, and
that's when I figured it out.
That's what's gonna happen.
The shit's gonna hit the fan tomorrow,
everyone's gonna melt, Proctor and J and J
and Pepsi are all gonna high five
and be like "See, fuck those fuckers."
But in the ashes are gonna be the actual
companies that put them out of business.
Which is why you should do that,
meaning just build
something that's profitable.
That's it.
- So tear it up and--
- That's it.
Your biggest, the two biggest things you
have to do is make sure creative and math
and insights are working
together, not separate
and you make a fuck load of creative.
The biggest issue for
them at four, six and $12
is how many creative variables
the agency is making.
That's it, the target's right.
23 year old dudes in fucking
shortage is not hard.
- [Man] So you'd do a volume of creative,
I mean that's the bitch, right?
We've been hearing about it all the time.
Would you also apply the
same principle to businesses?
- Yes.
- Volume of businesses?
- I thought you were going
with R and D of products.
- No.
- But with businesses--
- Yeah, new ones.
- Oh yeah, 100%.
Especially if you do R and
D that way, don't guess.
I would literally create a channel
on social media called Make
Pretend Products and just
post every day and see what
people give a fuck about
and then go make that orange
juice with coconut oil.
Why guess?
You had to guess because there was no way,
the internet didn't exist.
So yes I would but I would
do it the way I just said.
I wouldn't guess, unless strategy right?
You guys are a big company.
If Unilever or J and J or Proctor
has something that you're pissed off about
and there's good reason to fuck with them,
like hymns, you know
like things like that,
just to fuck, because you're
fighting a war.
So you're like you know what?
Let's go fuck around in that battle.
That good be a lodge, you know,
a place where you could
lose and still win, right?
Like if I was running a big conglomerate,
I would look at the place where
my biggest competitor is winning,
I would make a product that I was gonna
lose money on with the
sole reason of making
that brand seem not cool to the end user.
- [Man] And if you were
or had a big company,
would you buy any of
these little companies?
- If I felt the talent
in that company--
- So just for the people.
- Would be able to not
just drive that business
but drive the DNA of
the full organization.
If I was like these guys are so dynamic
and when I bought them, I'd be like "Look,
"I'm gonna pay you twice,
"you're getting 40, 50 million offers?
"I'm gonna give you 100, 100
"but I'm not giving
you dick until the end.
"I'm gonna give you five
now and 95 in year four."
Contractual, like we can't fire you,
you'll get it all and in four years,
you have to change the
DNA of the organization.
I don't give a fuck if
your little thing grows.
I need to fucking fix this.
- [Woman] Okay, I'll try and make it quick
but basically this year
for our outside company--
- Yes.
- [Woman] We are working
on empowering our staff--
- By the way, it's super smart.
If you can figure out
how to not let anybody
be the judge of the
creative, you will win.
- [Woman] That's kind of the issue now.
(laughs)
I know that it's not unique--
- Who is it?
Who's the judge in your world?
The CEO, a founder, two bosses,
somebody, like who is it?
- [Woman] The founders are very much--
- That's your problem.
- Involved in terms--
- That's your problem,
that's your problem.
- [Woman] They say are
gifts really our brand?
And it's like well it's
all so subjective--
- Them.
- We don't like it.
- So I've tried to really--
- You pound them.
Yes.
- Yeah.
- You educate them that their
subjective call is the vulnerability.
It's back to humility.
It's back to the wonderful
question he asked.
Like why doesn't that frustrate you?
Because I have more
humility than I have ego.
I mean I'm putting out content about me.
Forget about Empathy or
fucking a hotel or a sneaker
or a shaving cream or a vitamin,
and I'm wrong all the time.
It's me, I read all my
qual and I'm wrong enough.
That's what proved to me like if that's
happening with me, nobody's
deeper into qual, quant.
Like I'm in and it's
me and I'm producing it
and I know and I'm wrong, game over.
- [Woman] So it's coming
from the outside through,
you know, this is actually really working.
So let us do this.
- I mean literally, that's exactly
right and then just, you know what?
I think what I do well is
I get to the punchline quick, right?
If you go to the punchline quick
and I keep pointing because I'm
just so excited because I'm curious,
it's gonna be awesome to see what
you do or don't do but
it is the punchline.
If you sit down with two
founders and be like,
and this depends on if
you're willing to get fired,
have a good enough relationship
but if somebody just says
"Hey Joe and Johnny, here's the punchline.
"Your subjective fucking
call on if that's cool
"or not cool, good or bad means nothing."
- [Woman] That doesn't sound too good.
- The end.
That doesn't mean you can't have,
like when people hear me say that they go
"Well Gary, what about
the guy who said if I
"listened to my customers, I
would've made faster horses?"
Then I would say "Good."
Then you would put out the car,
the car would've worked,
then everybody would agree.
Back to businesses and products.
So if they're so right, let
them post four times a day.
By the way, you want to really work it?
Don't post on the Instagram account.
Run them as ads and see
what actually works.
You can run 1,000 pieces
of Instagram content a day.
Run them as ads, they don't
show up on the main page,
it's why everybody loves stories.
Everybody puts the main feed on such
a pedestal like it's your
fucking art in your home
but stories is just like
whatever, so people produce like
crazy for stores but are fucking
crippled by the main feed.
I just treat the main feed
like stories, better than most.
(mid tempo electronic, piano music)